Ariel Helwani always appreciate when he
comes on because I'm speaking to the
person who covers Mme better than
anybody else we take the good and the
bad with sometimes our guests and let's
go back to November 17th Ariel Helwani
of hosts of the MMA hour joined us we
talked about the possibility of
Mayweather and Conor McGregor to be
honest I think it's absolutely ludicrous
I think it's a it's a BS storyline
perpetuated by these you know these
morning debate shows because they know
nothing about mixed martial arts and
this is the only thing that they can
grab on to to meet look after the
Cleveland Cavaliers won in June where
those same shows going on television
saying okay that was great they made
history but how would they do against
the Denver Broncos because that's the
same kind of discussion it's ludicrous
it's embarrassing and any journalists
who actually seriously debated this on
Monday
two days after Conor made history at MSG
should be ashamed of themselves spring
in Ariel Helwani MMA fighting dot-com he
joins us now was this inevitable Ariel I
love that you guys played that clip I
was I was ready for it I was wondering
if you explained it and and I was ready
for it can I just quote a line from the
great Vincent Edward Scully yes in a
year that has seen be improbable the
impossible has happened and that's
really what happened here because you
have to go back to that day that we
spoke and and listen to what I said I
said any journalist who was talking
about this fight which at the time was
fictitious two days after Conor McGregor
and the UFC made history at MSG becoming
it to division champion breaking the
gate record at MSG not focusing on that
and focusing on this pipe dream of a
fight that connor's people have admitted
since was perpetuated by the talk shows
they sat around and said look look how
many people are talking about this let's
go after it that's what I was talking
about so I've never gone on the record
and said like this is never going to
happen but I do feel the same way today
that I did back then I wish people would
have appreciated the moment more but
here we are the impossible has happened
and you know why the impossible has
happened then the impossible has
happened because we could never have
foreseen what happened after msg and and
think about a year ago today year ago
today the UFC is not sold yet for four
billion dollars
Connor doesn't fight des for the second
time they don't go to MSG yet Rhonda
doesn't lose in her comeback so much has
happened since then and 2017 has been a
really down year for the UFC I believe
if they're enjoying the kind of year
that they were enjoying last year the
new ownership they don't make this fight
but they need a big fight it has just
been very quiet for them so they had to
get it done did the media make this
fight happen I think in large part they
did and and and that's not a knock
against the media per se again going
back to what I was saying in November
MMA is just a very young sport so when
you talk about the mainstream media they
didn't know what to make of Eddie
Alvarez they didn't know what to make of
the UFC's long battle to get to MSG they
didn't know what to make of the first
guy to ever be a champion into division
so like they did with Ronda a couple
years ago the first thing they grabbed
onto is this crazy super fight you know
Oh a no boxer against you know the
greatest of all time arguably and of
course the Ronda fight was even crazier
because that was a female against a male
and that's just you know that's really
insane but that's what they that's what
they wanted to talk about because they
didn't know what to make they didn't
know how to break it down in the morning
meetings and then and that's fine look
I'm excited this is great this is great
for all of us but it's it's still it's
still unfathomable here we have an Ono
MMA fighter who's never boxed
professionally or amateur fighting a 49
you know boxer as a professional let
alone amateur Olympics all that stuff
and more I mean we've never seen this
before well I know that they talk about
how they had to get this sanction and
you know Las Vegas got it somehow got
this sanction I I wish since it's a
spectacle aerial I mean it's not a
boxing match sure it's not UFC or MMA if
you did five rounds boxing and then you
did five rounds the MMA now that to me
is interesting if we're going to make a
complete spectacle out of this yeah then
why not go all the way there to say all
right Floyd you got five rounds to knock
him out if not then you're going to go
to the mat here with Conor McGregor
trust me I would love that I think I
agree with you I think that that would
be even more interesting but there's no
way Floyd would do that at this juncture
I mean he is a lot oh he's over ten
years older than him there's really
nothing for him to gain and doing
and credit to Floyd because you know I
never really believed that he was going
to call it quits on the cusp of making
history as you know no boxer has ever
gone 15 oh he's tied rocky Marciano's
record so here he has found the biggest
draw out there who just so happens to be
the least experienced fighter out there
right that he could fight them all even
if he fought you know some middle tier
500 fighter still more experienced than
Connor as a boxer I will say this though
I see a lot of my colleagues saying
Conor has no chance yeah I'm not going
to be that guy I'm not because I am I'm
tired of of not believing in what this
man says I truly you're being too smart
though Ariel because I said if you get
in the ring you have a chance that this
yes isn't you know where you know one
knockout punch helps LeBron beat Golden
State you got to win four games this is
I if I get lucky I can actually win this
fight and it'll probably take luck for
him to win the fight I truly believe
that he believes he has a chance to win
like he has a lot of self-belief he has
a lot of pride we all do to a degree but
he is not going in there just for the
paycheck the paycheck is great make no
mistake about it this is a victory like
right now the fact that it is a done
deal sign is a victory for him the rest
is all in many respects gravy because no
one thought that he could convince the
UFC UFC could have stood in the way of
this they owned his his fighting rights
no one thought that he could convince
them to play ball with Mayweather
promotions in Showtime they've never
done this before they never co-promoted
in the Zuffa era but again they need to
do this because of the sale and the dead
and alone all that stuff and and more
power to them they're not making a
hundred percent of the profit but
they're still making a nice chunk of
change but the fact that he got them to
do it that's a victory I have no doubt
in my mind that he believes that he's
going to win and I'm not going to be
though I can't believe when I hear
people say there's absolutely no chance
at hell how do you know he's done
everything over the last four years four
years ago Dan this man was collecting
unemployment checks he was about them
fighting his UFC debut on Facebook it
was even on TV four years ago that's
insane look where he is now about to
make 100 million dollars this is what I
wondered about is this good for the
sport
if Conor McGregor makes this money and
somehow doesn't stay longer
in UFC that I wondered about that once
you get that money is he going to want
to continue to train and do this or is
he going to want to do something be an
action hero or whatever his goal is in
life look they are playing with fire to
a certain degree there's no doubt about
that what if he wins and then they want
to do the rematch and you know who knows
what happens then but I do believe for
the UFC again it is a risk worth taking
because a they need something big I mean
they're going to make more money on
August 26th and they made in all the
pay-per-views combined in 2017 so it's a
risk worth taking in that regard also
this is a guy who's not even 30 yet and
he's not you know this is not a guy
who's going to sit on the beach going
into his for like he wants to compete he
wants to make more money he has been on
the record saying he wants to be a
multi-billionaire so he can't just walk
away from just making a hundred million
dollars one night so yeah
there is a risk there but I do know from
talking to his team that they want him
to fight at the end of the year they
want him to fight on that December 30th
pay-per-view and this is a massive coup
for the UFC and Conor for two reasons a
they they beat triple G Canelo by three
weeks so they'd be a punch on the
pay-per-view front and the earlier this
fight happens the more likely Conor
returns on December 30th so this was
good for the UFC it was good for
everyone involved because you know
they're standing to make more money I
think by going before triple G Canelo
and they're getting it done sooner
rather than later great stuff is always
ariel appreciate you joining us love
your honesty thanks so much guys
Ariel Helwani the MMA our MMA fighting
comm journalist the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience